um at first glance it was small enough
and it looked like a deer it was same
colorization and stuff like that it's
not a deer what Paul reinger spotted is
a kangaroo it got up and started
to not run along the roadway it started
hopping I had friends from Australia you
know message me and say you know that's
every day here it's no no big deal it is
a big deal in oshaa about 40 minutes
east of Toronto on December 1st in the
snow did you hear about a kangaroo on
the loose no I did not is it really a
kangaroo on the loose are you serious
yeah what do you think about that I mean
it's actually kind of cool pretty neat
doesn't freeze here no I have never seen
it de where did the marsupial come from
we visited the asua zoo they said their
kangaroos were all accounted for so who
does this one belong to it's not illegal
to own a kangaroo in the province of
Ontario because the only animals you
can't own in Ontario are a pitpull and
an orca leaving municipality to make up
their own bylaws in oshaa Kangaroos and
Wallabees are on the list of prohibited
animals in the responsible pet owner
bylaw we have such a LAX uh set of
provincial laws protecting exotic
animals from being held in private
menageries that this is exactly the type
of thing that is prone to happen it did
back in March this video went viral when
a lion at jungle cat World Wildlife Park
appeared to escape its primary enclosure
the owner had denied the allegations
surrounding the video the park also has
two kangaroos but they tell Global News
neither one is missing there's a long
list of ways an animal like this could
end up at large the CEO of the Toronto
Zoo which says it's also not missing any
kangaroos says these are not the type of
animals that should be in people's
private care and certainly not in urban
residential areas I think some people
are attracted to the Exotic nature of it
people who love these individual animals
um may or may not be qualified to care
for them late this afternoon durm
Regional told global news that a
delivery driver was transporting two
kangaroos Thursday evening to Quebec and
on Route stopped in oshaa to let both
kangaroos stretch their legs and that is
when one went missing police were called
here to search for the kangaroo and
could not locate it and hours later it
remains on the lamb Karen liberman
Global News